damn it how could this have happened
[Music]
here's something important to remember
about dialogue no one
ever in life starts a sentence with
danette
i'm in a constant state of writer's
block that is my default position
dialogue is pretty much where the art
comes in
taking some words that someone has just
said
holding them in your hand and then
punching them in the face with it
i left the west wing after season four
i have not seen an episode from seasons
five six
at seven together we are going to break
the teaser and first act of episode 501
of the west wing you don't have an idea
until you can use the words but
accept and then i just want to hear your
bad ideas very bad love it very bad
uh it was by the way it wasn't that bad
but it's a white house conspiracy
[Music]
look at this cork board this is two
hours that needs to be filled
the worst crime you can commit is
telling the audience something they
already know
you should be evangelical about
aristotle's poets
if there's something wrong with your
script that it's because you broke one
of those rules
it's not just that dialogue sounds like
music to me
it actually is music
then you have much less common days
where you did write and you wrote
something good
and you see it on a screen i promise you
you feel like you can fly i'm aaron
sorkin
and this is my masterclass
you